students parents teachers and community
members are asking some hard questions
tonight about last week's shooting in
South Florida those questions come as we
learn more about what the Florida House
Speaker calls an abject breakdown at all
levels correspond if he'll Keating has
the latest tonight from parkland Florida
my laptop was still there you know I
ungraded papers that were still there
for the first time since a hundred and
fifty bullets were flying during the
Valentine's Day attack teachers were
allowed to return to Stoneman Douglas
high to retrieve personal items
abandoned in the panic there was hugging
there was you know hugging there were
some tears there were handshakes they
were glad you're back glad you're back
you know I don't know I had enough hugs
to last me you know a lifetime today
this as disbelief and disappointment
raged nationwide after the revelation
that as the shooting was happening the
high schools resource officer ran to the
freshman building armed with a gun but
never barged inside that officer Scott
Peterson a 30 year veteran who was
awarded best school resource officer
four years ago for his tact and good
judgment according to Broward County
Sheriff Scott Israel had neither when it
mattered the most when in addressed the
killer killed the killer another misstep
at the scene officers who thought they
were watching a live feed of the shooter
instead were watching delayed security
footage the sheriff also has suspended
two of his deputies who responded to
some of the 20-plus calls for service to
deal with a volatile Nicholas Cruz in
the past few years one of those
instances involved a claim that Nicholas
Cruz planned to shoot up his school and
just months ago one of the dispatch
calls made by the confessed mass killer
himself this time suggesting he was a
victim
and some of the first responders to the
chaotic scene last week came from Coral
Springs PD speaking for the first time
officer Jeff Heinrich who was off duty
at the time rushed in as a cop as a
father of a student and husband of the
school's assistant athletic director hi
Gracie God when they walked out in the
hallway they found each other shelter in
place and Florida Republican Governor
Rick Scott today unveiling a half
billion dollar school safety plan a
three point action plan dealing with
modifying gun laws improving how we deal
with mental instability and also
addressing school safety for example
making sure there is at least one armed
officer for every thousand students at
every school in the state as for the
Stoneman Douglas high school students
they return here on Wednesday officially
getting back to school getting back to
their classrooms to finish off this now
forever scarred semester Brett that will
be tough Phil Keating live in parkland
Florida Phil thanks